the Joe Rogan experience and most of our
lives you see we're dealing with the
whole history of a species of structures
of domination oppression that's the
history of the species for the most part
and there's moments in which there's
breakthroughs in which there's a freedom
of spirits and then you have some
institutionalization of that which is
democracy that's what democracies are so
fragile and usually don't last that long
because it cuts so rapid radically
against the sense of really wanting to
be free I mean those Jeff's keys right
most people really are afraid of freedom
they want to defer to Authority they
want to conform and when they're
introduced to freedom and they really
catches hold it's like oh my god it's
tremendous cost to be paid but I like
that there's something about that and
they can hear it in the music they can
see it in your comic art the priors and
others and it allows these effects and
consequences that people's lives to
really enrich their lives before they
die why do you think people are afraid
of freedom
well it's courage I mean there is no
freedom without unbelievable
unprecedented unstoppable courage and
courage it's not widely distributed in
the species form they can place it
they're complicit in their cowardly they
well-adjusted injustice and want to
smile and walk around as peacocks rather
than cut against the grain and have to
bear witness and therefore end up on a
cross or like Socrates condemned I most
of the great figures that we know yeah
and there's more consequences for that
now than ever
oh yeah cancel culture that's exactly
right
yeah no it's true it's very very true
but I mean we live in a culture that's
so corporatized commercialized
marketized it's all about money money
money status status status and you lose
any deep sense of honour of character
it's all about what appears to be the
case it's the culture of superficial
spectacle so it's all about image yeah
you see yeah and image is just
some surface phenomena but I can't
recommend your book race matters enough
and one of the reasons is because of
your analysis of that your your
understanding of this the superficial
aspect of the pursuit that so many
people are locked into from cradle to
the grave and you just you encapsulated
that so well and and the way you worded
it and the way you phrased it it's it's
so it resonates so well and I I really
admire this lifelong pursuit that you
have for not just understanding these
things but explaining them in such a
succinct way where it's absorbable like
the that book it's in the 25th
anniversary I wanted to talk to you
about it because that's the one I read
and it's so strange when you read
something that's so it's so current even
though it's 25 years old it rings true
and does that sometimes does that feel
futile where you you you have the same
issues for that you spoke on 25 years
ago and it's very little change in those
25 years no wonderful deep question no
matter I appreciate you times that you
spent reading our race matters but no
it's never a futile no man it's never a
futile because you have a conception of
victory that is not messianic or
salvific you know trying to save people
you're not trying to be a messiah to
bring some kind of grand gospel to
people you're simply trying to touch
people's lives so when you enrich and
enable person's life to win which you've
talked about that right there you
already talk about the ways in which you
were touched mm-hmm
that means there's no futility at all
yeah you know it's certainly not if you
took me as the fecundity of it it's all
we can do you know as human beings is to
try to inspire one and
and encourage one another and enable one
another and Noble one another in that in
and of itself was what the great John
Coltrane called a force for good how do
I become based on a Love Supreme
a force for good in a cold and cruel
world hey star love supreme absolutely
absolutely
and love supreme is not a love in the
abstract right it's a love of beauty in
its concrete forms it's the love of
goodness in his concrete forms it's the
love of truth in its concrete forms now
I'm a Christian revolution at Christian
so I got a love of God mediated through
a Palestinian Jew named Jesus but that's
tied to a justice it comes out of
prophetic Judaism right and we know
Judaism Christianity Islam all of these
religions for me I have no wholesale
monopoly on how we understand the world
because the all emerged various
historical moments but when it comes to
this love that allows us to persist in a
world in which cruelty and envy contempt
manipulation dishonesty and this shot
through all of us no we're not finger
pointing the name car